this is the story of a man named stanley
it's incredibly bold to hide away a
sequel to a game in an expanded
re-release of the original experience
but when it comes to something as
enjoyably strange and hilariously obtuse
as the stanley parable it makes sense in
fact my belief that the stanley parable
ultra deluxe would be anything else
seems fundamentally foolish in hindsight
all of his co-workers were gone what
could it mean
stanley decided to go to the meeting
room perhaps he had simply missed a memo
ultra deluxe is as intriguing to play as
the original game perhaps even more so
today given that its messages directed
towards the modern day gaming landscape
some of the nuance will be a bit lost on
you if you weren't playing games or at
least paying attention to the space back
in 2013 as it relies on having a grasp
of how the conversation surrounding
games has evolved in the past decade but
it's an entertaining experience
regardless of if you have that context
or not the next time the screen asks you
to push a button do not do it
you see
can he just not hear me
how can i tell him in a way that he'll
understand that every second he remains
here he's electing to kill himself
though it's presented as a kind of
director's cut of the original ultra
deluxe feels more like a sequel that
exists within the stanley parable you're
still kicking things off by embodying
the role of stanley an employee with the
meaningless role of sitting in a drab
office and staring his computer screen
all day pushing the buttons on his
keyboard that he's told to and then one
day his screen stops telling him what to
do gifting him with the freedom to
listen to the overbearingly haughty
narrator that oversees his every move or
to do as he wishes instead look stanley
i think perhaps we've gotten off on the
wrong foot here i'm not your enemy
really i'm not i realize that investing
your trust in someone else can be
difficult but the fact is that the story
has been about nothing but you all this
time
there's someone you've been neglecting
stanley
someone you forgot what really
i was in the middle of something do you
have zero consideration for others are
you that convinced that i want something
bad to happen to you of course it's not
really freedom when given the option of
walking through a door to the left or
the right stanley isn't really being
given an option at all he's being
funneled down one of two possible paths
each of which can branch into several
predetermined outcomes upon reaching any
of these conclusions the game resets to
the beginning allowing you the chance to
try a new path and uncover another
outcome it's all a fake freedom meant to
reflect the illusory sense of choice the
player is presented with when they play
any game that's advertised as a choice
driven narrative this was a far more
intriguing narrative setup back in 2013
when such self-reflection in video games
wasn't entirely common and the game
design choices it commented on were more
prevalent in 2022 it now feels like
we've already had this conversation the
industry has since built upon this topic
to create games that comment on a
specific experience through some level
of retrospection on the theme of choice
and how it works within a medium where
the recipient of the message isn't a
passive observer like the notion of code
switching and adopting new speech
patterns and signs of sojourner or
investigating power and privilege
through varying degrees of anatomy in
disco elysium ah welcome back you may
have noticed that this room has begun to
deteriorate as a result of narrative
contradiction but not to worry now that
you're properly informed on good
decision making we're going to revisit a
choice you made just a few minutes ago
and see what the correct thing to do
would have been i wouldn't go so far as
to say that this makes the opening
minutes of ultra deluxe boring but it
isn't a great first impression for first
timers either given how outdated the
commentary can feel for a little while
at least you're just playing the
original game which is no longer as
unique as it once was
making these opening runs through ultra
deluxe feel a bit outdated thankfully
you can just skip straight to the new
content if you want with the game giving
you the option right off the bat if you
choose not to you'll need to play
through the stanley parable a number of
times and see a few of its different
endings in order to unlock the new
content
much of the new content plays similarly
to the stanley parable allowing you to
follow the narrator's instructions or do
the opposite you can press the button or
not press the button you can jump or not
jump you can carry the bucket or not
carry the bucket so stanley what do you
think do you like all of the new
features yes i know it's not exactly
clear yet how exactly these features
will come together as one single
coherent video game but i can feel it in
my soul it's going to work there's
definitely a good game in there
somewhere say let's do an experiment
your choices will cause the story to
branch allowing you to reach several
different endings some are immensely
entertaining variations on how the
experience could already conclude in the
stanley parable while others are brand
new all of them are rewarding to uncover
with some surprises tucked into a few
the main crux this time around is how
the illusion of choice is redirected to
encompass the gaming industry more as a
whole since 2013 the relationship
between developers and players has
changed with bad faith players realizing
they can weaponize social media to
demand changes to games and developers
learning the never before needed skill
set of balancing the desires of an
insatiable player base in their own
artistic vision when any possible change
can potentially be achieved through an
online update it truly brings a brand
new almost horrifying meaning to the
stanley parables tagline phrase the end
is never the end is never the end
oh no oh god no stanley it's a
collection of reviews from pressurized
gas the extremely popular online
storefront for computer games i haven't
looked at these in years i can't even
imagine what's being collecting down
here
surely these reviews were glowing as
well weren't they
it's a compelling concept to explore the
idea that whether a developer listens to
their players is just as arbitrary as
whether a player decides to go through
the door they're told to when playing a
game the stanley parable sort of
broached this back in 2013 when some of
its endings imply that the illusory
sense of choice in games could be
extended to other forms of interactions
like your role in the workplace or
conversations at home with your family
ultra deluxe just focuses that idea on
game development and then runs with it
delivering an experience that's
hilariously funny but can also be spooky
or tragic and i dare say that some of
the new endings feel almost wistful
regardless of their tone what i've seen
thus far has convinced me that i need to
keep playing this game again and see
what other outcomes i can uncover
okay so far it's an elevator nothing
special yet but i'm sure it's just the
beginning of a mesmerizing adventure
um
is it broken what's going on here should
we
should we be moving somewhere
oh there we go all right finally at long
last it's on to the new content i've
never been more ready let's do it to say
any more about this game could
potentially spoil some of its delightful
surprises of which there are many the
stanley parable ultra deluxe has taken
me on a roller coaster of emotions i'll
be scratching my head in confusion one
moment and staring at my tv dumbfounded
my mouth a gap in incredulous amusement
the next as far as i can tell there's no
unifying mystery to solve here or is
there any sort of indistinguishable
moral lesson that the game is asking me
to uncover what is there however is an
attractive lure for a thought-provoking
experience about video games and how our
reception of them has evolved
[Music]
the stanley parable is both a richly
stimulating commentary on the nature of
choice in games and one that offers some
of the most enjoyable surprising and
rewarding choices i've ever been
confronted with in a game 9 out of 10
don't you get it stanley the game was
perfect it didn't need anything else it
didn't need new content all they had to
do was transport it in pristine
condition along to the nintendo switch
boom done and they couldn't even do that
couldn't resist the urge to go meddling
with a beloved franchise